uh we have a guest we have one or at
this point I mean friend okay he's been
on the show so many times we've hung out
with him he's one of the [__] realist
and coolest dudes we know
he he is the uh he's the like the a
pedophile hunting version of the Bear
Jew yes exactly Stephen Crowder I'm just
kidding Alex who's in everybody hey yo
what's up buddy what's up man what's up
what's up good to see you dude
good to see you all too it's a it's a
pleasure to be here um I thought I was
going to take a break from like
interacting with pedophiles but you know
here I am
take a day off bud I know we had no idea
pasty was going to be here we didn't
know we had no idea
hello my brother boy very very very very
very bad okay they're taking over the
show Mercer's two of them now
what's up man dude you've been [__]
killing it dude you've been [__]
killing it yeah so why I gotta hear the
lit this so this yeah the hot gosh the
hot guys we got a uh I gotta ask before
we even get into this was this a dude
was this particular dude somebody that
you were
talking to me about like a few months
ago when we were up there
no no
so this guy was totally random we were
actually on the way down to Eagle Pass
Texas to go confront a guy we had on the
list for over a year at this point
um we couldn't find him so I just like
opened up my grinder app um in San
Antonio and this account happens to hit
me up and you know I'm posing as a 14
year old boy and I see wait hold on Alex
hold on a second
I think I thought grinder would have
safeguards so 14 year olds wouldn't get
off yeah I thought you weren't even
allowed to be on those kind of apps
unless you or anything at all well
you're supposed to be 18 but they don't
check ID verification or anything what I
mean well okay
I'll confess I read one of the books in
like the local elementary school about
how to get on grind without your parents
knowing so okay look I'm an educated guy
all right all right good he reads books
guys so I'm sorry so you were saying you
uh you were presenting me 14 on Grindr
correct so
um we exchanged phone numbers
um and then I look up his phone number
and I run his info and I see that he got
arrested for child pornography in August
of 2022 and that he was a middle school
teacher and I'm like holy [__] and you
know he was okay with the age and I gave
him all these outs like hey we don't
have to talk we don't have to talk and
he you know he set up a meeting to go
have sex with his 14 year old he pulls
out last minute and you know he's too
nervous because he got caught like less
than a year ago by the cops and
um so I see that he has a telegram
account and I saw that his name on
telegram was literally boy lover and I'm
like oh he's up to the same [__] as he
was last year so he went to his house
the next day and I confront him and he
agrees to talk to us in the in the span
of like an hour he admits that he has
possession of uh pornography as young as
infants uh Toddlers and all that stuff
and that he actively trades those very
images so um the cops came and they
ended up arresting him on the spot for
uh you know Bond violation and you know
now today he's charged with possession
of child pornography and online
solicitation of a minor so he's
currently uh [__] so he was already
still on pre-trial release like
obviously because it was August 2022 I
would imagine they're still going that
like he's probably like you know
whatever dragging that out so I'm sure
he's still in court for that so like you
said oh so he's kind of cool that's not
you know here's the thing right not to
compare the two right but these people
have such a sick pathology because look
10 years ago I got a DUI right an old
Mikey really cooled off on the drinking
and the even at home like you know what
I mean when you [__] up and you go to
jail for something generally go
I gotta hit the brakes maybe I need to
change some [__] but to just be like
right back out like
oh that's terrible I mean that's like
that's like you're out and it's like you
can't help you cannot [__] help
yourself no that's what it is like in
you know the video is going to be out on
Predator poachers on Rumble
p-r-e-d-h-e-o-r space p-o-a-c-h-e-r-s if
you don't want to see it when it drops
in a few days but um yeah he was telling
me in the video that he can't help that
he's wired like this he's like I don't
want to be Wireless I can't help it and
from what it seemed like his
um his preference seemed to be like
five-year-old um
um you know but he was of course a band
teacher at a public school so I'm sure
they vetted him very not I'm sure they
knew about his telegram activity that's
probably why they let him into the
school but um that's a prerequisite yeah
I can say they want you to do some field
work before you start working there holy
[__] man that's [__] what dude it's
it really it really is [__] insane I
always complain when like when you come
on the show I always complain about the
fact that you just always seem to have a
pile of like in your inbox of course
yeah you know it's like it's like it
literally like the old school like
cubicle from the 80s and he's sitting at
a desk and his owl box and stuff but his
inbox is just a mountain of [__] and
it's it's reinforced by the fact that
you're like yeah we came all this way
and a guy backed out and then I just
tripped over a guy on Grindr in five
minutes [__] yeah it was I mean this was
definitely just by chance and you know
obviously our profile looked young so
that's probably why he went after it but
man dude we I I just can't believe how
stupid he was I mean he probably could
have gone away with it if he just didn't
give out a real freaking phone number
but I mean you would have gone away you
got it you would have got away with it
too if it wasn't for [__] those kids
and take the mask off of him like some
[__] Scooby-Doo you're driving around
round like some [__] Scooby like in
your mystery machine but instead of
ghost you're taking down pedophiles well
it's funny that the pedophile Hunter
drives a van and the pedal wouldn't be
driving the van but like you know
whatever I will say these guys usually
get like heartbreakingly light
punishments but I will say this worked
out really well because if this guy was
on pre-trial release and he's up to the
same [__] when they get the center even
if he gets a deal now when they go to
sentencing they're gonna be like wow
you're [__] Brazen dude look they're
not gonna let that slide at sentencing
oh yeah like he Bear County where San
Antonio is we caught him in Converse
Texas which is like a suburb of San
Antonio but um that county is like light
on these people and
um dude but he's screwed like I they
they're his bail is like 175 000 right
now and you know he doesn't have that
type of money I don't think and he was
already facing 20 years on his first
charge because I think him being a
teacher might be another charge I don't
know I don't think so actually but like
you know they'll definitely consider
that when it comes to sentencing and
dude if he was face he's I think he's at
least going to get 20 years for all this
[__] I mean dude this is like I mean it
just goes to show that they they always
will reoffend there's no helping these
people ever no I mean I agree 100 I mean
100 and it really is it really is
[__] insane like Marsh was saying
like how easy like you said you just pop
you pop an app on him within minutes
like that's all it takes like it's not
even like you're it's not even like
you're like you're you're in the
underbelly like you're just going to
normal stuff that people can access and
be like wow like it's out there and
nobody cares and I and I know from which
we've read articles grinder is
particularly bad when it comes to that
yeah so in 2019 when we first started on
Grindr it was like the wild west I mean
it was constant messaging but people
kind of smartened up on grinder
Grinder's gotten a lot more restrictive
because a lot of our videos in 2019
before YouTube moved us over and over
again they'd go crazy and I would make
like you know I'd say very nice things
about gay people in those videos and
grinder definitely took note of it and
they tightened up their [__] but I mean
still it's so easy to get on Grinder
like they don't have any ID verification
and I think it's kind of on purpose why
they wouldn't have that
um but they should know I mean it's
pretty easy to not allow miners on these
apps but you know they just don't they
just don't take that step it's weird
I was gonna say they want to have the
bigger they want to have like more
registered users that's all it is they
don't want to put too many barriers up
because then it's like ah because even
adults are gonna go I gotta put in my
shoes well that's the same reason
Twitter doesn't really really want to
get rid of bots so it's it's kind of
exactly because it keeps the number yeah
boost the numbers it makes you look good
Paul nugget which I'm which is one of of
your fans uh uh uh Alex said uh join PP
for seven bucks a month and you'll have
more pedo catch videos uh than time and
then he uh posted the link to your
locals which is
creditapproachers.locals.com I highly
recommend it to you guys that even even
if you liked watching Alex on YouTube
back in the day or whatever when he
wasn't getting nuke left and right like
even then you had to start muting words
and like you know what I mean like it
just gets it's fresh like go to the
locals it's great because now you're
just gonna get here's the catch baby
because and locals has been like I mean
I know we all have our little issues
with Rumble and locals here and there
but Alex has more than but it's been at
least
unrestrictive has it not yeah yes no we
locals is great because
um
you know we we can drop uh how do I put
it uh n bombs with the Hardy yard
nuclear bombs to these Predators
um you know verbally of course and we
can also
um use the f word to them too and I you
know that's been very refreshing because
there's some predators we catch that
can't go to jail for example we caught a
we call this Predator who's going after
a subscriber's daughter online but he
was so careful because he was only
asking for stomach pictures of her and
that's not illegal to ask that even if a
10 year old which I think is [__]
ridiculous but it's not illegal
nonetheless and he wasn't budging on
that because I ended up taking over her
account and you know I was trying to get
him to say anything that could break the
law and he just wasn't doing it so I'm
like all right well we'll just go
confront this guy but um yeah no we we
dropped a lot of uh Choice words on him
that would have caught me through well
that didn't actually get me thrown off
YouTube so um are you no I gotta ask him
great I I've been meaning to sign up uh
but I just haven't organized my locals
but uh I I will be signing up today
because I've been meaning to do that
just because we support you guys uh are
you putting the older stuff up because
there's there's some there's some
there's some throwback ones that I like
to go back and watch that were very
cleaned up for YouTube but like one of
my favorite ones was the one I always
bring this one up was the one we were in
Houston and you started getting a little
too political because you were
frustrated with the current leadership
in that City and how they just keep
letting people get you kind of went on a
[__] rant in a Walmart parking lot
but like third three quarters of it was
just mute
and I really want to hear that clip
dude but I've ranted so many every every
time we're in like a Soros County I rent
so many times like yeah nothing's
probably gonna happen to you but I
[__] hate you and you know it it it
does get frustrating in some places but
you know San Antonio is I mean that's
astorious County and they've taken up
our cases so I don't I don't know maybe
our case are just good or the D.A would
be on the hot seat so who knows whatever
it is I'm just glad they're getting
taken up some way somehow I would
imagine San Antonio still has enough
like sort of red leaning people around
though to you know because you have to
enforce certain things guess what
the Revenge of this is Logan's account
just signed up for predator posters
thank you okay cool we're in there you
go we are in and we're in for a year we
made the year we did the whole year
which by the way and everyone's heading
for locals honestly this is the truth
it's the better deal because you get two
months for free it is two months for
free for free alpha males that's two
extra months of learning how to be a Top
gay yes well this guy whoa okay I don't
want to mislead this guy we confronted
it's on locals but he's actually a
bottom a g okay oh he's a bottom spoiler
alert I hadn't watched it yet God damn
it oh my God he's just the bottom there
seriously
um yeah and of course your Local's
contribution does go to saving uh well
allegedly saving Colombian kids five
thousand miles away that you'll never
hear about again after a quick little
video so wait wait a second you don't
wanna you know I'm not worshiping the
sound of Freedom made by a neocon
Mexican
dude the thing is I mean it doesn't
matter Carlos Slim is one of the good
Freemason billionaires you have to
understand that he's one of the good
ones that's what they say dudes why tell
people if you want pound for pound the
best results support Predator poachers
because these guys actually like put
tread on tires burn gas I mean it's as
far as I can tell you're always on the
road catching another Predator yeah
basically you just stop for gas in
Wendy's I'm like if you want seven bucks
a month to go a long way instead of like
100 million in laundered money I'm like
these guys at least get results
whoa whoa the money doesn't get longer
they go to they go to sting operations
that might happen like once a year come
on dude all these come on it takes
millions of dollars to just set up a
sting operation you have to understand
merge dude have you heard the stories
about like the what this guy does the
what's his name that the producer Guy
the one that's behind us the Shady
behind the scenes guy in this movie Tim
Ballard
he does the from what I heard this was
in an article that allegedly he gets
these like marks these rich marks that
are like so into this like save the
children like Rick grift that he'll
charge them like big time money to have
like a little like a couple people from
his organization will just come set up
some laptops put on some headsets and
act like they're saving kids and like
triangulating like shipping containers
with kids in it it just makes these
people feel good that's what I heard you
know you know what like oh we'll come
and use your like luxury condo as a war
room for the day and it makes us like
Rich donors feel like I'm helping you
know what this has to be I don't know if
you remember this episode of South Park
Alex but it's a good thing she's
no this [__] really thinks he's Jesus
now he went from playing Jesus to I'm
gonna cut my hair and be short-haired
Jesus this reminds me of this reminds me
of that episode Alex have you seen the
the episode of South Park
um It's the episode of South Park where
uh the Family Guy and Cartman's like
people are always walking up to him and
be like oh my God you must love family
guys so so your humor is that what's
happening with you in this movie it has
to be right where everyone's like have
you seen each other Freedom sound of
Freedom have you seen what did you think
about it saying you guys it's like
looking in a freaking mirror you're the
same it must suck right oh yeah dude
it's been it's been you know I
understand it because you know I was
open to I mean I haven't seen a movie in
years because I just don't trust
Hollywood in general but you know these
people are a part of Hollywood they're
not ostracized from Hollywood they're
ostracized from Hollywood and they'd be
actually ostriches from Hollywood they
wouldn't allow them to make this movie
but they'd be on cozy
on cozy exactly
yeah I mean it's just the whole thing
like it's like telling someone to wear a
mask because it'll protect Grandma it's
like making it's like asking people to
do the bare minimum and they think it
actually accomplishes something and I
think that's like a whole complacency
scheme going on because it's literally
really just telling people you're
fighting human trafficking by watching
this movie that's [__] ridiculous and
that's not something I want to fall for
and it's raising awareness yeah Alex
what about remember his awareness and
we'd be Advocates because when you're an
advocate you advocate for more awareness
yeah and then here's my cash out I'm
aware can I bring that you're advocating
yeah bring up your cash app
it's it's
uh it's a dollar sign podesta 69 420.
that's my cash app
no but I mean it really it really does
it feels I don't know man none of this
[__] is sincere honestly it just feels
like neocon's grifting on the Q Anon
people right that's what it feels like
right like they're just grifting on them
they're not really stopping anything
it's not really raising awareness it's
not the best movie that's ever been made
either and he looks like he wants to
look at us she wants to be Jesus
and another thing is like the guy
literally is on a Jordan Peterson
interview I think it was Jordan Peterson
saying that he watched child pornography
[Music]
I mean he should be in jail for that so
yeah isn't that the Pete Townsend
defense that's a Pete Townsend defense
from who to prepare for this role it was
it was absolutely the utmost importance
to me that I understood the character so
I consumed massive amounts of child
pornography and they're like Mr Depp
what are you admitting here I had to do
it for the role
god dude and like eat and I can't
believe even after even after seeing
that video people still defend him for
watching child pornography you know like
literally somebody somebody defended him
saying but Alex Jim is doing the same
thing you do and I'm just like how is
Jim acting in a [__] movie the same
thing the same thing is actually getting
Predators arrested man these people are
just so I mean it's a spell man it's a
spell I'm not gonna say they're stupid
but it's just a spell they're under no I
mean I think I I you know what it is to
Hope horn
um it's like where people go like see
now they find because there's this weird
like you were saying like you were
winning guys but like you were saying
exactly what you were saying earlier
Alex was like you don't trust Hollywood
[__] these guys I don't want to watch a
movie the last movie I saw in theaters
was top gun Maverick and it was just
because it was [__] Jets and I was
like oh that's [__] cool I like Jets
like an autistic person but but the
people people go we don't like Hollywood
we don't trust them but then they do
though these conservatives want to be in
look at Ben Shapiro is a great example
right he wants to be in movie theaters
he wants to make movies you don't hate
Hollywood you're just mad that you're
not in it that and then they go well I'm
gonna be in Hollywood even if I have to
play their [__] games or work with
[__] Mexican Mexican slimy Clinton
people I don't care and and they'll sell
your soul like everybody else does to
make a movie that really at the end has
not saved anyone and will save nobody
the awareness has done nothing
oh 100 I think if anything the the
awareness has said people it makes
people think like oh well I did my part
okay on to the next current thing we'll
find something else to care about now I
think that's literally what it does and
you know until uh Jim cabazel and Tim
Ballard and um who else is in it uh Mel
Gibson who's promoting until they drop
any names in Hollywood I'm not going to
take them seriously if they actually
cared about pedos they would care about
the pedos who were probably filming
their movie for them and who are
literally living blocks down the street
from them in Hollywood but they they
would never name any Hollywood actors
who are pedos they would never talk
about Epstein's Client List and nor
would they ever try to get legislation
passed to fix any of this [__] they
would never and that then they haven't
they saw a giant Cash Cow in the
right-wing grift and they were like yeah
of course we could do this and we could
like streamline it and we could just
make money off these marks and that's
all they're doing now and instead you
should get five dollars to our locals at
revenge of assist on locals.com all
right we're not we'll we much like Alex
we also say the n-word a lot and fries
really that's yeah and we just we won't
sell out not because we you know have
integrity we just has like a whole it
sounds like being dishonest and then
having all that like
obligations to disgusting people sounds
exhausting no and our locals our locals
is filled with a bunch of people has
told us I'm a guy I'm a guy that just
feels I'm a guy that just feels nice
about a nice sandwich smoked a little
weed if I'm sitting by a pool yeah you
know just having a beer I'm satisfied
like these guys that are like I need a
golden boat and kids to [__] on it like
yeah just like okay yeah nah man I I uh
I'm just I got my toes swirling around
in water I'm cool
if it's you want to go to aft pack or
you want to go to TP USA there's a guy
who knows a guy and we can get a booth
and meet like nah that [__] that can we
get a couple of Nations here Sergeant
cojones five dollars it's hard the
Predator uh it's so hard that Predator
poachers will never be short on content
these people are numerous and are
everywhere yeah we're just saying that
uh he's the real Tim balance your
favorite bomb statute says Alex is a so
proud of you we are all
#alex local members in the house you dig
yeah you know that's my girlfriend that
calls me that's [__] hilarious well
yeah she has eyeballs does she have a
sister Oh Betsy
all I'm saying is I've dated I've dated
black women I've dated Jewish women and
when I'm having sex I've said all kinds
of wild [__] yeah sure good point yeah
well my girlfriend is actually Muslim
believe it or not and I actually play
the role as a pedophile dating a
nine-year-old Muslim like Muhammad did
in order to understand the people I
catch that makes sense right I like that
wait what is this I mean does that make
sense that's what it's [__] Rosen and
sriracha and a race to like give birth
to the Antichrist yeah no exactly no no
I don't know the Antichrist Baby First
Strike it's a very good point
um so yeah I mean it's it really it
really is like you were saying it's all
this is all this is all [__] shows
anything anybody that Jordan Peterson or
[__] Ben Shapiro are platforming are
[__] garbage they're [__] garbage
people they're stupid they're all
running the same [__] a lot of those
guys are represented by [__] what is
it let's look at William Morris not
William Morris the other one the Ari
Emmanuel one like a lot of these people
have legit Hollywood agents but they're
out here going like guys we need to be
[__] based in red pills and I'm like
and you're like you give 25 off the rip
between the ADL and your management and
all of a sudden you give you got to give
all [__] show up to all this [__] you
don't believe in touch on all kinds of
walls and [__] you know what I mean take
all these flights and release you don't
want to take and go suck [__]
zielinski's dick in Ukraine [__] all
that I'll take five bucks a month yeah
no yeah exactly exactly I mean dude I
mean I don't know like I mean I I mean
TP USA and stuff like that like I don't
know why the left shit's on TP USA I
mean what I've heard there's a lot more
butt sex in TP USA than San Francisco
that's what I've heard though if you I
mean if you have y'all heard stuff like
that before yeah it's just not kinky
enough butt sucks for them I'm sorry are
you saying lady Maga isn't a stand-up
dude
wait ladybug is a dude uh oh you have to
make some phone calls don't you happen
to me too but don't feel bad all right
when you get off this interview I want
you to Google Blair white and then pre
-transition yeah see what pops up
and I hope it's not an erection
do the same sound of Freedom
conservatives that are watching that
stupid [__] movie dude they're the same
people I comment like when Blair white
posts a picture of himself in like a
bikini saying oh that's so hot that's so
hot oh don't tell my wife
it's the same group of people it's the
same people that like Brody sheoha Blair
white wasn't Tom McDonald's new video
shut up well this is why my my big thing
now the big thing I argue with with
right Wingers and conservatives now is
the they have this D transition movement
right and they're moving the Overton
window where it's like I D transitioned
now I want to talk to your kids about
how I de-transitioned whereas a few
years ago it was like look I don't want
the regular trainees talking to my kids
about cutting and [__] [__] and I
don't want the ditch because like you
you d-trans can't talk to kids without
them giving the [__] you can't talk
about the sequel without knowing the
prequel so you're still [__] Trojan
horseing your way into talking to kids
about oh it's [__] [__] I want you all
to go away
d-transitioners are not you're not
de-transing you're a double [__]
you're literally a double Troon you
transition twice I want you far away
from your kids you're a maniac you can't
even stick to being trans and they're
like I want to talk to your kids no it's
like Ollie London is somebody that I
[__] hate for that very reason Ali
London is this [__] guy that wanted
to be a Korean pop singer and then and
then then when that didn't work he then
he became a trans person now he puts on
a football jersey goes I'm a man and I
really [__] you want attention oh that's
the problem man and then that's honestly
why we like people like like Alex it's
like you're there's no sincerity in
these a lot of this [__] a lot of it's
just like going with the waves or
whatever of whatever's cool to talk
about now you know nothing just now
people are starting to say stuff like oh
this Ukraine thing might actually be bad
but at the [__] beginning everybody
was like oh yeah you we gotta go there
we even Republicans like yeah I know
whatever let's [__] go and you're
like dude what the [__] ever no one is
sincere you go with the move and it's
whatever sells [__] mugs or leftists
to your goddamn tumblers
literally yeah it's literally a false
hope and oh guys we want the House of
Representatives back everything's gonna
get better now Biden is literally going
to be stopped it's I mean I think after
2024 I mean this is like the last sliver
of any give a [__] I have about politics
yeah let me go [__] after this I just
don't care anymore and you know but then
it's the same people I mean the same
people that speak out oh
anti-communition anti-socialist they're
all supporting Trump man he's like the
most socialist president we've had in
like the [__] 20th like in these more
socialist than Obama was you printed
more money I mean it's just bro it's all
just [__] if I if I hear if I see
one more [__] tweet from like
Patriots trucker69 that says [__]
that tells me yeah oh man aren't you
ready to lock up uh everybody after what
Biden and fauci did and I'm like did
everyone forget this Miss Trump and
vouchy am I the only [__] that
remembers am I going insane yeah that's
a very good point it's like well you
gotta remember Trump didn't force
anybody to take the vaccine he didn't so
that six-year-old girl that died of a
freaking bloated heart in her sleep but
Trump didn't force that on her I mean
her parents might have because they
believe what Trump said but he didn't
force that on her so it's not it's not
his fault that she died and I'm so sick
of hearing that garbage [__] I mean
Trump needs to go to jail for crimes
against humanity just like as a
researcher and right sorry
yeah it it it's amazing that it's like
well I didn't make anybody get it but
you sold it and you pushed it and you
said it was a tremendous thing and you
said everyone should get it which is the
equivalent of yeah and then still
defending it and that's the other thing
we're still defending it we're still
saying it's the best thing ever now you
don't trust this guy I don't get it I
mean he has wood behind him he's a man I
don't see what the issue is sure sure
his daughter allegedly left her husband
and kids to go allegedly have sex with
Andrew Tate sure
I built this studio with leftover lumber
from Joe Rogan's bloody Green Room
oh my God
water wait his daughter actually did
that with Andrew she left her husband oh
yeah oh buddy buddy buddy buddy
sometimes you forget the youth sometimes
because we always red pill him on [__]
and he goes yeah that was and then we
realized it was seven years ago I forget
he's a young guy yeah he's a younger
it's not like you were always looking
for politics guy let me help you out
here oh yeah that's not a doctored photo
that's not a doctored photo that's a
real photo yeah she ran off with her
husband
oh he oh my god oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah she took a picture one
time with her medicine cabinet and one
of the drugs she had was a Valtrex of
course she didn't realize it was in
frame yeah
it wasn't even the medicine cabinet she
posted a picture of her prescriptions oh
that's what it was and like somebody
looked them up and like this is for uh
and that was pre-tate yeah that was
pretty oh no I guess he's Andrew tainted
now
um yeah no but like so again man it's it
doesn't matter because I don't even need
a cure I defeated the herpes virus with
my mind and taking has come out because
they've been asking him he's like I
never had sex he says they're lying look
at this picture I'm gonna pull this
picture up you don't think these two
[__] get the [__] out of let me tell
you something I ain't posing for this
photo with you lest we [__]
do you have any bottled water you've
just been eating meat since you've
gotten here the only way I would take a
photo like this with somebody and not
[__] her is if she was like somebody I
knew and paid to professionally take a
photo and I feel like all right fine but
if I took this photo naturally right I'd
be like oh believe I [__] her
that's a candy Jordan Peterson's more
mad about Anonymous accounts on Twitter
just trolling him than that happening so
I mean I don't think he even gives a
[__]
um Maca uh no it's I don't even care
that my daughter was used like bloody
Chinese finger cuffs by the Tate
brothers
because we have Anonymous troll demons
yeah dress like a goddamn Batman villain
[__] you Jordan Peterson back to taking
your pills Grandpa seriously and we'll
bury you in your Twitter suit
I saw a picture of Andrew Tate at an
Israel Symposium with the Israel flag
behind them for my daughter he's got a
magnificent [__] he wore my daughter out
like stretched denim but at least his
penis was spotless
diversity is our strength as long as he
has good ideas it's okay that he did
that to her oh [__] all right Jim let me
ask you a couple of questions if you
don't mind do you want to first of all
tell people
um about your involvement with Angel
Studio somebody in the chat says uh
y'all y'all are you all are acting like
you're So based what do you suggest in
regards to the sound of Frida thing
actually catch pedophiles like [__]
this guy's doing that's what I suggest
you do not actually [__] make movies
about maybe catching them actually doing
it yeah that's it what you do is you do
something about it two countries I think
like 50 60 arrests I think like 30
something convictions yeah so I don't
know something like that this this guy
over here is actually doing something
about it that's what you here's how I
know when I can trust people or if I
know I'm gonna like people yeah when
when if you were to ask them to give an
elevator pitch or what they do and then
you go oh yeah but do you really and you
can immediately cite like recent cases
of it you know oh well fair enough then
so that's what he does like we literally
watch him oh no then they go they go in
regards to Trump I don't know not hire a
vaccine salesman yeah not hire a guy who
just said
main thing is by giving him even more
missiles here's what you do sir you want
my advice yeah you keep going you keep
going into the world's over right you're
gonna keep going into work and
pretending like everything's hunky-dory
but you're gonna quietly buy a lot of
ammunition and seeds and um get ready
for a future you're gonna have very
little control over oh and get some life
straws yeah it's essential the problem
is is like Pat you know Alex nailed it
politics is all [__] now anyway what
the [__] are you gonna do about they
don't care these people all Vote for
This they're gonna vote harder though
yeah we're gonna vote we're going to
vote our way out of this one suck
everything [__] sucks
local Politics the solution is the
people around you like the Sheriff's
Office and [__] like that like the
things that affect you locally and the
people that can actually do something
about stuff that's way more important
than losing the [__] White House
absolutely I mean honestly Joe Biden's
presidency has probably been better than
Trump's because
um you know I'm not ever going to vote
for Biden but you know States became a
lot more based ever since Joe Biden's
been in office in response to how [__]
up he is
like a slow control demolition both
Biden it's like total chaos so States
like kind of tighten up and are like all
right well we're putting a stop at this
[__] I don't think that would have
happened under Trump to be honest so I
mean that's that's my two cents I mean
all the states have started passing the
detransition stuff was because in in in
response to what Biden was doing they're
like the states that did that were like
we're not doing this here we're not
doing anything [__] off go somewhere
else you know and and I and I what do
you do about it I don't know but the
fact that you think that there's a
[__] they're doing the same thing
over and over again the solution is
silly to me right they gave us covet
because we voted for Trump homie yeah
that's why we got it exactly and the
thing is like dude everybody like
pretends to [__] on like welfare
Universal basic income but when Trump
was doing it during of it everybody's
like oh base Trump for giving us two
thousand dollars instead of six hundred
dollars thank you Trump it's like they
don't actually have any values they just
worship man and I mean I get it because
I think I think Trump is like a big
coping mechanism for people it's not
actually it's policies because it's
policies are left as [__] man I mean
printing money left and right and gun
control all this [__] it's just the idea
of trump that they like the idea of like
oh I'm going against the media or I'm
going against the establishment bro he
is the establishment you can be outside
of politics but still be in the
establishment if you're donating to both
candidates or both parties for 30 years
you're in the [__] establishment
especially being in New York city so
people just need to wake the [__] up and
quit being [__] [__] honestly
yeah no amen and also something else bro
I saw you through 275 and pump out 10
reps you [__] machine
Jesus Christ dude you're an animal what
the [__] and I like guys like I haven't
really been to the gym yeah and then he
goes home really go to the gym and then
he [__] cranks out 10 at 275. geez is
Christ dude that is I mean I don't go
too often I go like probably half the
month or something you know when I'm
home and not uh not on the road catching
pedos see look look I'm like I'm like
hey see I
don't know you look like you've lost
weight I think you've lost it since last
time yeah
that honestly you've definitely lost
weight since I saw you in Orlando oh
yeah yeah for sure but so how much was
this two seven how much was this three
that's that's 340 that's my last wrap
[__] off how many did you do with 340
well just one it was the last it was
like at the end of the end of the lift
okay I could do 375 for one I want to be
clear here okay I'm not a competition
but the difference is I actually have to
try really hard not just go half the
month
this is insane and and you're also like
what how tall are you six what
six four [__] this guy I would be
terrified I'd answer all your questions
too yeah it is kind of goofy how
terrifying his presence is but how like
like soft-spoken and like friendly he is
I know yeah yeah what's up dude no
that's cool man look at that food not
even a
Sprite dude which is a good by the way
that's a good psychological handle to
have on like these photos because it's
like okay this guy's ginormous he knows
I want to [__] kids but he isn't
immediately caving my skull in like a
gorilla
people just get very compliant because
you're like nah man come on it's a bench
over here just come sit down we'll talk
and he'll [__] officer high tower
because you really don't have a choice
yeah what do you do yeah I think I think
I think it definitely helps for sure I
mean I try to give advice to like this
chick that catches predators and because
I saw a predator walk off on her and I
was about to say like hey you should I
just said ah well not yeah it's probably
because I'm like a foot taller yeah
that's why it's it's hard it's hard to
it's hard to be physically it's right
like a five foot something thrown across
the room what's he gonna do
um
but do yeah this this is like what you
do is [__] awesome dude and it's
honestly from when we some from the
first thing you've been on the show
until now you have blown up like on
Twitter your tweets your catches like I
mean you're getting the record well yeah
and they had blown up you just kept
getting [__] Zapped that was the
thing yeah and it was kind of unfair too
and I it really is [__] because
there's other people that do what you do
way less effectively uh and and with way
less results but for some reason they
were allowed to thrive and and get the
little check marks and get that like get
this get basically get the same [__] in
yeah but yeah and I'm not gonna name
names but we probably and it's like it's
weird because I'm starting to read now
about how like all of those shows that
are still on YouTube that are doing well
I'll have to check one they all they had
to do the same thing I was saying
earlier you have to there's a management
company agency and they're part of an
MCN and you got to give them a cut of
your money and then they let you in on
this like the the actual algorithm and
it's like a whole [__] game dude
everything's just a [__] rip-off game
yeah I mean you know the way I look at
it though is like yeah it sucks that we
got taken down seven times and other
channels have been taken down like once
or none but I mean you know I don't
especially when it comes to [__] like
pedo catching I don't think misery loves
companies a good mentality to have I
still think you know I'd rather I'd
rather me just be taken down than all of
us get taken down because in the end
they're still catching Predators but you
know I mean obviously there's a sense of
like oh man they're so lucky this that
but I mean you know them getting taken
down wouldn't help [__] and sure as hell
doesn't bring me up so I'd rather some
some like be able to not be taken down
than all of us so so you know no no I
mean look man I want everything to be up
I say Sunshine's the best disinfectant
if it's not illegal content like that
that [__] Yama Kamikaze guy that
[__] creepy cult guy that was from
Hawaii that this dude caught a while oh
yeah that guy I blew up on the internet
and I got so mad at those people because
he was out advocating openly for better
Philly on his video and everybody went
yeah we got this reported it's taken
down I'm like yeah so it's gone there's
no evidence like now I mean I'm sure
people downloaded it but we had a time
stamp verified YouTube video this guy
self uploaded where he's like oh I love
the [__] kids like leave it up like
there's no kid [__] in the video and
now we got this [__] dead to
rights and everybody's like reported and
you're like yeah
aren't you signaling bro like it always
is it's like when I've seen it took it
down I've seen people go like to people
they suspect like you know they'll
whatever they'll look at like you know
if they'll figure out somebody you're on
a live catch and they'll start yelling
at the persons on their Facebook wall
before you even have a chance to get in
there and it's like shut the shut up you
know what I mean I know they're already
gonna start nuking [__] shut up yeah
like they don't understand that these
pedos like Josiah for example These Eyes
literally in custody right now because
we knew about him because of freaking
Free Speech because he put that video
out there we knew to me well we didn't
message him first we knew to follow him
on Instagram and he messaged us and then
he set up a meeting with who he thought
was a 13-5 year old we knew that because
of free speech so you know when you when
you think you're doing something great
but oh I'm reporting this because you
said something gross no you're not
you're not you're not helping [__] and
it's kind of what the Instagram band
like
when the whole [__] was like the oh the
Predators communicate with pizza when
that went out that I was like good I'm
glad Instagram's starting to crack down
but it was kind of mixed feelings too
because half the pedos we were talking
to on Instagram all got nuked and now
there's no trace of them anywhere and
we're not gonna be able to go confront
them and get them arrested and like
you know I understand like obviously I
don't want people communicating that way
but we also exploited their
Communication System Too in order to
freaking throw our decoy in that little
suggested search thing and we got so
many arrested because of their stupid
hashtags they use but no none of them
are going to get arrested um they got
taken down because Instagram saved their
ass they did it on purpose and you're
right there's two sides to that because
like you said if you are made aware that
that kind of shit's happening you do
have a moral responsibility to be like
we had to shut that down but like like
you said when you do it like in Mass
like that and you don't understand the
other side of the coin which is no no
we're casting a net right now we're
gonna scoop up like 50 of these dudes
yeah it's literally and the thing is
like Instagram doesn't report any of
that [__] to law enforcement they just
take their accounts down and that's the
worst because then those pedos go to
Telegram and if we go to telegram that's
a big risk for us because telegrams
where they send all that [__] like
Instagram we can communicate with them
and like oh yeah yeah you're into that
blah blah blah but none of it's actually
event so we're good and we can just use
those messages and confront them with it
but telegram would be risky for us
because obviously we don't want to be
implicated for you know anything you
don't want a Jim Caviezel situation
where you have to watch right yeah well
dude that actually motivate me to catch
them I have to watch it full video
his movie's coming out soon it's called
shofar of Justice okay
well played very very funny next time
you do a catch do me a favor ask him if
your Alpha and they're Haram tell them
that right now they're not being Sigma
males and they're not doing things
correctly they'll know what it means
well since Muhammad dated a six-year-old
isn't Predator catching itself for him
I want to see Alex on the front page of
Rumble one day like oh yeah live catch
with it guess special guest Andrew Tate
oh that tastes just there just like what
the hell is the matter with you you're
supposed to be sexually exploiting and
raping adult women
all right like a man yeah you're
supposed to be you're supposed to be a
dominant alpha male don't Circle the
high school Circle don't Circle the
elementary school Circle the high school
yeah
and wait till they're at the prom
Community College
Pro tip be a limo driver you can get him
to be cam [__] easier and Alex is
sitting there going that's what better I
guess I guess oh I guess it's a
compromise
dude we're at six o'clock man we just
hit the end of the show I just realized
what time it was Predator poachers on
Rumble and locals go sign up these guys
do [__] amazing work like yes for
real yes
p-r-e-d-a-t-o-r space
p-o-a-c-h-e-r-s Oh it's being it's being
generously generously spammed in the
chat oh yeah yes completely free to of
course up to us on Rumble and let's hope
we can get on the front page one of
these days because Rumble loves to
suppress our [__] even though we um even
though we uh how do I put it
um even though we have numbers that
represent that represent where you
should probably be on the front page and
um yeah they also don't have live
streaming from the app which I know I
know they need to do that dude they have
the button right it has the button for
it though there's the buttons there it's
a coming soon it says coming soon on it
well that's right so actually what I'm
gonna do is I'm not gonna find a
baseball oh actually this is this is
great so I'm actually going to switch my
genre of what I do right now so I can
get on the front page I'm actually can
read articles and um
right now I like it I like it there it
is now now you'll be on the front page
next today we're going to go over
someone else's work and writing right
now and I'm gonna give my take on it
that doesn't go too far doesn't push the
Overton window too far okay hear me out
on this I'm gonna help you out I'm going
to give you a freebie right now when we
end this stream you start a stream and
in all capitals you're gonna write four
ways Trump can win with all with a bunch
of exclamation marks that's a good point
and then your thumbnail should be
something that like looks like like
looks like the news but it was made on
Fiverr by an Indonesian by the way
you're on the front page right now
because we're on the front page
all right well we got to see on the
front page let's give some really base
takes guys okay let's go limb here
you're only gonna hear it here okay
let's hear it there's only two there's
only two genders
I love it I [__] love it and you know
what capture it's going to save this
country that's what I think cat turd is
saving the country guys you know what
and I gotta say this I think these these
uh these liberals these demon wraps I
call them lip Tarts they're so worried
about these kids getting shot in schools
but they sure ain't worried about kids
in the womb they're not worried about
Planned Parenthood sure all right are
going against down to Freedom they're
all pedophiles themselves all right make
sure you get our food buckets all right
Owen's calling me I gotta go on Infowars
now
tell on we said hi tell him we said hi
okay everyone go over there and watch
them
later uh Predator poachers on Rumble
thank you to the people posting in the
chat and uh if someone could please post
the locals one more time because I'm not
logged in yet God that was that was so
good this is fun that was so [__]
great yeah uh I'll tell you what man
it's better you get more out of the
[__] seven bucks a month from them
than you do the you know a 20 ticket to
sand the freedom that was great I love
that he was going to be all in show we
love how I don't want [__] rules